it isn't 42 and you don't need sandals
and a beer to understand it there are
four things that make life meaningful
firstly helping others the most
meaningless life would be to have to
roll a boulder up a mountain repeatedly
because what makes life meaningful is
doing something useful for other people
we often think the nicest thing is to be
served but that says nothing next to the
joy of serving others fixing their
hearts teaching them trigonometry
helping them to build the meaning of
life is service it's also to make
something that's better than we normally
are we're all a bit of a mess anxious
furious forgetful so there's meaning and
creating something superior the train
set that's more organized than we are
the garden that's pretty in a way we
aren't always the book that says what
you normally can't finding out our stuff
works is also meaningful gravity a
foreign language computer code and best
of all who we are what drives us and
what we should aim for lastly meaning
comes from connections with others the
opposite of superficial chat is when you
show the vulnerable scared parts of you
to another person the best way to
kick-start a meaningful conversation
just ask what are you really afraid of
so that's the meaning of life
you